[Musik]
So, bei uns geht’s jetzt los. Wir sind jetzt schon am Flughafen
hier bei uns am Schalter bei Turkish Airlines.
Sarah und Josh sind mit dabei.
Für uns geht es jetzt gleich in die Türkei nach Istanbul.
Hier geben wir gerade unser Gepäck auf.
Wir haben echt extrem viel Gepäck,
denn wir sind jetzt 10 Tage in der Türkei.
Wir haben unser ganzes Kameraequipment dabei, wir haben alles dabei.
JOSH: Leider ein bisschen viel.
SALLY: Leider ein bisschen eskaliert.
Deswegen haben wir tatsächlich einfach ein Upgrade, also Business,
gebucht, sodass wir alles mitnehmen können.
Wir werden ganz gemütlich hinfliegen und dann geht’s gleich los.
Da vorn steht schon der Murat – auch schon eingecheckt.
Dann sehen wir uns gleich im Flugzeug wieder,
denn es geht in die Türkei! Oh, ich habe die Türkei so sehr vermisst.
Vor allem haben wir dieses Jahr auch keinen Urlaub gemacht.
Jetzt verbinden wir so ein bisschen Urlaub und alles andere
- wir nehmen euch alle einfach mit.
SECURITY: ... dass Sie bei der Anreise,
im Flieger oder so, sich infizieren?
MURAT: Da habe ich auch Angst. Ich habe immer Angst, dass ich mich infiziere.
SECURITY: Quarantäne... Also Sie wollen mich jetzt veräppeln?
MURAT: Ne, ne, ne, ne!
Wirklich! Quarantäne am Urlaubsort hätte ich auch Angst!
SECURITY: Gut. Und Quarantäne bei der Rückkehr vermutlich auch?
MURAT: Natürlich habe ich Angst.
SECURITY: Ja, gut.
Unsicherheiten bzgl. der Einreisebestimmungen auch nicht?
MURAT: Habe ich auch nicht.
SECURITY: Nervende Coronaregeln: Maske etc.?
MURAT: Nein, ist alles okay!
SECURITY: Sein Geld im Falle einer Stornierung nicht zu bekommen.
MURAT: Nein, habe ich keine Angst.
SECURITY: Wegen Flugstreichungen oder Grenzschließungen...
MURAT: Habe ich auch keine Angst.
SECURITY: Gut, dann haben wir das alles durch.
MURAT: Es ist alles das Geld meiner Frau.
SECURITY: Nur noch für die Statistik: Sie werden bei der Rückreise,
nehme ich an, auch wieder hier landen?
MURAT: Ja, hoffentlich!
SECURITY: Ja, das wünsche ich Ihnen auch!
[Alle lachen]
SECURITY: Darf ich noch fragen, wie alt sie sind?
MURAT: Ach so. Ich bin 38.
SALLY: Der Körper ist 38, der Geist ist 8. [Murat stimmt zu]
SECURITY: Gut, dann habe ich wenigstens heute
auch mal was zu lachen gehabt.
Ständigen Wohnsitz haben Sie hier? [Murat stimmt zu]
Man muss ja sehr viel Humor an den Tag legen hier am Flughafen.
Ich bedanke mich sehr und wünsche Ihnen ganz viel Spaß.
MURAT: Vielen Dank!
SECURITY: Und bleiben Sie gesund!
MURAT: Guck mal, Sally! Da ist jemand und hat eine Frage an dich.
PERSONAL: Saliha Hanım, merhaba. Hoşgeldiniz. Nasılsınız? İyisiniz inşallah.
SALLY: İyiyim. Siz?
PERSONAL: Teşekkür ederim. Kızım videolarınızla büyüyor.
Kısa bir mesaj gönderirsiniz, çok mutlu oluruz.
SALLY: Tamam.
MURAT: İsmi neydi? (Wie war ihr Name?)
PERSONAL: Pelin.
SALLY: Also er ist Mitarbeiter bei Turkish Airlines
und hat gerade gesagt, seine Tochter schaut gern meine Videos
– ob ich nicht eine Videobotschaft schicken würde.
Das mache ich natürlich gern!
Burda Almanyada yaşiyorsunuz, değil mi? (Sie leben hier in Deutschland?) [Er stimmt zu.]
Ich nehme sie ganz kurz ab.
PERSONAL: Kızım adı Pelin.
SALLY: Hallo Pelin. Merhaba. Wir sind gerade auf dem Weg nach Istanbul
und dein Papa hat uns gerade angesprochen.
MURAT: Ja, er ist gerade hier.
SALLY: Er hat gesagt, du schaust gern unsere Videos.
Ich hoffe, dass du zu Hause auch ganz viel kochst
und backst für die Familie.
MURAT: Ja. Ganz, ganz liebe Grüße von uns. Mach’s gut!
PERSONAL: Herzlichen Dank.
SALLY UND MURAT: Gern!
PERSONAL: Çok teşekkür ediyorum. (Vielen Dank!)
SALLY: Rıca ederim. (Gern)
MURAT: Alles okay! Gar kein Problem.
SALLY: Immer das Gleiche!
MURAT: Ich habe mein Ticket...
SALLY: Vorhin hatte er den Autoschlüssel verlegt,
um zum Flughafen zu kommen.
Jetzt hat er zum 3. Mal das Ticket verloren. Unglaublich!
Haben wir jetzt alles? Tasche 1, 2, 3, 4? Sehr gut!
SALLY: Hallo. Hoş bulduk.
Also alle sind durch. Kommt mit! Wir steigen ein.
Also momentan sind echt die Sicherheitsstandards sehr, sehr hoch.
Jeder kriegt Temperatur gemessen, alles wird doppelt kontrolliert.
Gibt es eigentlich Essen an Board? [Personal bejaht] Ja! [Lacht]
Guck mal bei Murat! Das sieht aus, als wäre das nicht sein Gurt vom
Flugzeug, sondern als wäre das der Bauch.
MURAT: Hör auf!
SALLY: [Lacht] Privatsphäre.
Jetzt haben wir unser Essen bekommen und klar,
unter Pandemiebedingungen ist natürlich alles einzeln verpackt,
damit nirgends eine Ansteckungsgefahr ist.
Jetzt beim Essen dürfen wir auch die Maske herunternehmen.
Es ist auch so, dass, wenn man nebeneinandersitzt,
man nicht gleichzeitig die Maske herunternehmen darf.
Da gibt es auch Sicherheitsvorkehrungen, aber wir sind ja verheiratet.
Was er hat, habe auch ich. Was ich habe, hat auch er.
Das haben wir uns, als wir geheiratet haben, versprochen. [Murat bejaht]
Wisst ihr auch, was das Coolste ist?
Dass wir jetzt Netflix gucken können und nicht gestört werden. [Lacht]
[Musik]
JOSH: Murat? Sagt das jetzt was über uns aus, dass wir 2 die
Rolltreppe nutzen und Sarah und Sally laufen?
MURAT: Ja. [Josh lacht]
Übrigens, der Zeugwart des FC Wacker Burghausen.
Ich habe die Maske richtig? [Josh bejaht]
[Musik]
Jetzt sind wir in der Produktion, ziehen alle Sicherheitskleidung an
und dann geht’s los.
[Musik]
Hier steht überall, dass man hier nicht filmen
und auch nicht fotografieren darf, aber wir sind das erste Kamerateam,
das in die heiligen Hallen darf
und sich die Produktion anschauen darf.
Da nehme ich euch jetzt mit und zeige euch,
wie Glas im Allgemeinen hergestellt wird und vor allem,
wie Sicherheitsglas hergestellt wird, was so besonders daran ist.
Kommt mit!
[Musik]
[Sally moderiert an]
Und... Du hättest es die ganze Zeit schon machen können.
[Zerspringendes Glas]
MURAT: Super. Das wollte ich schon immer mal machen in meinem Leben.
SALLY: Sollen wir es nochmal machen? [Murat bejaht]
[Sally moderiert an]
Kannst du mich vorwarnen?!
MURAT: Ah, Entschuldigung! Ich wollte das...
SALLY: Ich bin gerade mitten im... Weißt du, ich bin...
MURAT: Ich wollte das schon immer mal in meinem Leben machen.
SALLY: Das müssen wir jetzt...
Wir müssen jetzt die ganze Moderation neu machen.
MURAT: Okay, dann mach es!
SALLY: „... schon an dem Berg, dass das hier...“ Murat!!
MURAT: Äh, ich wollte das schon immer mal machen.
Guck mal, das ist voll der Hammer! Guck mal!
[Zerspringendes Glas]
SALLY: Ja, man sieht ganz krass, dass das Glas,
selbst wenn er es heftig schmeißt, einfach fast nicht kaputtgeht.
Ich wollte schon immer... Sollen wir dich hier draußen lassen?
[Zerspringendes Glas]
Murat, kommst du bitte aus dem Spieleland?
MURAT: Ja, noch einmal!
SALLY: Komm!
MURAT: Oh, was ist das? Boah, das ist noch gut.
[Musik]
2 Pommes bitte, 1 Pizza und 1 Köfte im Brötchen. Danke schön!
SALLY: Wie baut man so etwas? Wie plant man so etwas? Wow!
Guck mal, der Jumpsuit!
SARAH: Oh!
SALLY: Wow! Okay, okay! [Lacht]
SARAH: Wir kommen!
[Musik]
SALLY: Zeig!
MURAT: Nein! Nein! Kommt!
[Musik]
Ich nehme euch jetzt einfach mit.
Also wir machen einfach so eine komplette Shop-Tour, weil ich glaube,
ich kann kein Regal hier auslassen.
Also allein, wenn ich hier schon das Geschirr sehe – richtig schön!
Ich glaube, ich lasse einfach mein ganzes Gepäck hier und packe die
Koffer voll mit neuen Dekor- und Gebrauchsartikeln.
[Musik]
Wenn es Murat nicht sieht, kaufe ich das alles. [Lacht]
Boah, das ist mein Laden, ich sag’s dir!
Wie schön ist bitte der Kaktus? Ich bin so anfällig für Kakteen?
Plötzlich interessiert mich Geschichte doch.
„Ich bin dein Vater!“ [Lacht]
Oh, das wäre was für den Frank, aber Frank, es tut mir leid,
ich habe keinen Platz im Koffer. Sonst hätte ich es dir mitgebracht.
[Musik]
Hier ist so ein ganz kleiner Bazar; ist nur die eine Straße hier.
Ihr seht auch schon, es sind nur Einheimische da.
Wir gucken uns hier ein bisschen um
und zeigen Josh und Sarah ein wenig Istanbul.
[Musik]
SARAH: Ja!
SALLY: Das ist auch so ganz typisch, dass man hier das getrocknete
Gemüse verkauft, also getrocknete Auberginen zum späteren Befüllen,
getrocknete Tomaten oder auch Paprika zum Befüllen,
damit man einfach hier im Sommer die große Gemüsevielfalt nehmen
und für den Winter aufbewahren kann. Das ist nämlich ganz wichtig.
[Straßenmusiker]
Türkischer Mokka gegen das kleine Mittagstief.
Ist doch schon ganz schön anstrengend.
Oh, wollt ihr Lokum? Josh? Magst du Lokum? [Josh bejaht]
Ja? Wir trinken den Mokka und du kriegst Lokum.
SARAH: Ich kann das nicht trinken.
Ihr habt irgendwie ein Heiß-Gen.
Josh und ich bei Çay: Alle fertig und Josh und ich „Puh! Ah!“
SALLY: Murat trinkt den Tee so heiß, dass, wenn er das Glas abstellt,
es immer noch dampft. Das kann ich auch nicht.
Das ist auch nicht gesund für die Speiseröhre.
SARAH: Er kann zum Supertalent. [Sally stimmt zu.]
[Musik]
Das ist der Laden für Sarah, von Sarah – der Katzen-Store.
Das ist auch so typisch: Hier ist ein Waffelladen,
direkt nebendran ist ein Möbelladen,
daneben dran ist ein Laden für Braut- bzw. Männermode
und direkt daneben dran ist wohl der schmalste Laden,
den ich in meinem Leben jemals gesehen habe.
Das ist halt Istanbul – alles durcheinander
und ungeplant gebaut und gewachsen.
[Musik]
JOSH: Warum sitzt ihr so weit auseinander?
SALLY: Mindestabstand.
[Alle lachen]
Komm, wir sind ein Haushalt!
Ich meine, wann sind wir schon gemeinsam auf einem Boot
über den Bosporus gefahren? Schatz, das sind unsere Flitterwochen!
Oh, das ist so romantisch!
[Jubelschreie und Applaus]
Sie hat ja gesagt!
Okay, so ein Antrag wurde am gleichen Abend ungefähr 20-mal gemacht.
Doch nicht so einfallsreich.
Herzlich willkommen, meine Damen und Herren, bei „Nur die Liebe zählt!“
Gerade hatten wir einen richtig romantischen Heiratsantrag da vorn
auf dem Boot. Oh, „Seni çok seviyorum“ steht hier! Ich liebe dich
sehr, möchtest du mich heiraten? Und sie hat Ja gesagt! Wir hatten
so Gänsehaut, Sarah und ich!
Selin und Gökhan, alles Gute für euch.
Hadi seneye de düğüne geliriz artık.
Gehen wir zur Hochzeit! Oh, das Restaurant! Oh wow!
[Musik]
Ich fühle mich gerade wie im Film. Ich sitze gerade unter der
Bosporusbrücke. Hier ein fabelhaftes Essen. Jetzt haben wir hier
unsere Vorspeisenplatte. Das ist eigentlich überall ganz ähnlich.
Also es ist wirklich so, dass man dann Auberginenpüree hat,
getrocknete Tomaten, verschiedene Dips und Salate.
Ich glaube, wir machen jetzt die Kamera aus und genießen unser leckeres Essen.
[Musik]
„... Zum einen natürlich angefangen hier beim...“
[Lacht] Äh Cut! Warte mal! Ich trinke den kurz aus. Gleich nochmal!
„Ich würde sagen, ich genieße jetzt...“ das Rauschen des Helikopters.
Hörst du ihn laut?
JOSH: Nein, es geht.
[Musik]
[Lacht] Zeig erst einmal Sarah mit ihren Haaren.
Sie wollte grade ein Selfie machen, aber es geht nicht.
Nein, mach ruhig deine Selfies weiter.
Wir sind heute hier auf einem Boot unterwegs, ein privates Boot,
muss man dazu sagen, denn jetzt zu Coronazeiten
gibt es auch gerade keine Gemeinschaftsboote.
Also hier sind echt die Regelungen total streng.
Deswegen sind wir hier ganz privat in unserer kleinen Minigruppe
und machen gerade eine Bootstour über den Bosporus.
Hier auf dem Bosporus seht ihr auch gerade hinter mir direkt
den Dolmabahçe Sarayı. Das ist ein Palast,
der für den Sultan Abdülmecid gebaut wurde.
Der ist wirklich schön; da war ich auch schon drin.
Das ist aber schon über 10 Jahre her.
Ich glaube, jetzt momentan kann man gar nicht rein - wie gesagt,
wir vermeiden auch Menschenansammlungen, Touristen und Menschen.
Deswegen sind wir hier einfach nur allein unterwegs
und sehen alles aus der Ferne
und ich zeige euch ein bisschen etwas, was es hier noch gibt,
denn später kommt noch Galata Kulesi – ist für euch voll interessant,
ist voll die coole Geschichte.
[Musik]
Ja, ich flechte jetzt Sarah einen Zopf. Wollt ihr mitschauen?
Das wird eine Herausforderung, aber wer Ela einen Zopf flechten kann,
der kann es auch auf so einem Boot mit mega krassem Wind,
denn bei Ela ist es so: Wenn ich ihr einen Zopf flechte,
dann drehe ich mich so fünfmal im Kreis mit ihr,
weil sie immer wegrennt. [Sarah stimmt zu]
Komm, Challenge accepted!
[Haarspray]
[Lacht] Ich glaube, das bringt gerade gar nichts.
Professional Hairstylist, bei jedem Wetter, in jeder Lage!
SARAH: Ah! Sag mal! [Beide lachen]
Reißt du mir die Kopfhaut ab?
Ich halte mich an Sarahs Haaren fest. [Beide lachen]
SARAH: Ah! Sie killt mich! [Beide lachen]
JOSH: Hast du gerade gegrunzt?
[Alle lachen]
SARAH: Sieht das eigentlich komisch aus? Ich halte sie nur.
SALLY: Kannst du noch höher mit dem Kopf?
SARAH: Also, wenn ich nachher keine Haare mehr auf dem Kopf habe...
SALLY: Arbeiten unter Extrembedingungen, würde ich mal sagen.
Oh, ich muss nur aufpassen,
dass ich da hinten nicht die Treppe herunterfalle.
SARAH: Du kannst dich ja an mir halten.
SALLY: Ja, mache ich ja gerade!
SARAH: Meine Kopfhaut so wegziehen.
Also ich muss sagen, ich habe schon Angenehmeres erlebt.
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Jetzt komm! Führ dich nicht auf wie so ein Kind!
SARAH: Wie ein Dennis? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Führ dich nicht auf wie Kevin.
Kevin, falls du das siehst... Kevin hätte schon längst geweint.
Sarah, geht’s?
SARAH: Ja, mein Hals bricht gleich.
SALLY: Ich finde es selbst immer so satisfying, zuzugucken,
wie dieser Zopf entsteht, aber Josh interessiert sich nicht für
unseren Zopf; er interessiert sich für die Natur.
JOSH: Ja, ich muss doch einen schönen Schnitt hinbekommen,
mit so einer Türkeiflagge im Wind.
SALLY: Guckt mal, wenn ihr dann die Zöpfe so geflochten habt
und wollt, dass sie noch voluminöser aussehen,
dann könnt ihr sie einfach hier ein bisschen mit den Fingern öffnen,
damit einfach der Strang ein bisschen dicker wird, auch hier oben.
SARAH: Ich tu mal meine Ohrringe wieder rein, okay? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Ich reiße sie dir nicht mehr aus.
JOSH: Was ist mit dem Move?
SALLY: Ach das war dein Model Move?
SARAH: Hä? Was soll ich denn machen?
SALLY: Ja okay.
SARAH: Ich habe jetzt keine Haare mehr zum Wehen.
Die sind alle im Zopf. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Magst du das so lassen oder soll ich sie dir oben...?
SARAH: Ich kriege schon fast Kopfweh.
SALLY: Echt? Ich finde sie voll schön!
SARAH: Ich mag es nicht, wenn so alles aus meinem Gesicht ist.
SALLY: Sie ist so selbstkritisch.
SARAH: Aber hat sie schön gemacht. Ich habe sie zwar nicht gesehen,
aber es fühlt sich gut an.
SALLY: Schön hier, gell? [Murat stimmt zu]
Da ist gerade Beylerbeyi Sarayı.
MURAT: Ja, das war der Sitz der Sultane.
SALLY: Hier war früher alles Wald.
Schatz, vertraust du mir?
MURAT: Ja, warum? Oh mein Gott!
[Titanic-Musik] Das ist doch richtig Touri jetzt, weißt du das?
SALLY: Du musst jetzt sagen: „Ich fliege!“
MURAT: Ich fliege! Ich fliege!
Hat das nicht Leonardo DiCaprio gemacht?
SALLY: Ja, aber er war größer als sie.
MURAT: Ach so.
SALLY: Also müssen wir es andersherum machen. [Lacht]
MURAT: Bescheuert!
Wahnsinn, da kommt ein Piratenschiff. Eisberg voraus!
[Sally trällert]
MURAT: Hör auf zu singen! Ich schwöre, ich springe!
Hör auf, ich springe!
SALLY: Spring nicht, Jack! Spring nicht!
[Fotoapparat]
Da hinten seht ihr den Galata-Turm,
der auch Mädchenturm genannt wird, also Kız Kulesi.
Da gibt es auch eine Geschichte dazu. So wurde sie mir erzählt:
Und zwar hieß es, dass der Sultan einmal bei einer Wahrsagerin war.
Sie sagte, dass die Tochter sterben, also getötet werde.
Dann sperrte er einfach seine Tochter oben ein
und ließ sie nicht mehr raus, damit ihr einfach nichts passiert,
weil er seine Tochter einfach über alles liebte.
Es kamen im Prinzip nur Essenskörbe zu ihr nach oben.
Da war es dann so, dass eines Tages
ein Essenskorb zu ihr geliefert wurde.
Im Essenskorb war aber eine Schlange, die sie biss, vergiftete
und sie eben daran starb. Die Geschichte wird zu dem Turm erzählt.
Er ist ein richtiges Wahrzeichen von Istanbul.
Ich selbst war noch nicht dort. Wir hätten jetzt auch gern angelegt,
aber wie gesagt, zurzeit wollen wir das nicht.
Deswegen haben wir jetzt den Turm von außen begutachtet.
[Musik]
Ganz interessant zu wissen:
Hier hinter mir ist gerade der Ortsteil Paşabahçe.
Da, wo dieser eine große Kamin ist,
war auch die allererste Fabrik von Paşabahçe.
Da waren die Produktionshallen.
Aber weil das Ganze zu zentral in der Stadt war, haben sie es
nach außen verlagert und produzieren deswegen nicht mehr hier.
Vor allem haben sie außerhalb einfach auch ein bisschen mehr Platz.
Also die Hallen waren ja schon ziemlich groß,
aber hier ganz historisch die allererste Fabrik.
[Musik]
So, ich bin gerade in Istanbul im Stadtteil Beykoz.
Mein Vater hat vor ungefähr 30 Jahren ein Grundstück hier gekauft.
Seit 30 Jahren besteht dieses Grundstück und da ist ein Haus drauf.
Jetzt suche ich einmal dieses Grundstück und ich hoffe,
ich finde es jetzt gleich und schaue es mir an.
Also ich mache mich jetzt auf die Suche. Kommt einfach mal mit!
Okay, das war jetzt ziemlich abenteuerlich, das zu finden.
Ich weiß noch, als Kind war ich hier.
Das ganze Haus hat mein Papa mit meiner Mutter zusammen gebaut.
Kommt mal kurz mit!
[Musik]
Okay, das ist anscheinend das Grundstück von meinen Eltern.
Wie gesagt, hat mein Vater vor 30 Jahren für 25.000 DM gekauft.
Da kriegst du heute nicht mal mehr die Garage dafür.
Guckt nicht nach der Architektur. Das ist damals einfach so gewesen.
Das Coole ist, das ist saumäßig modern,
wenn man Fliesen an die Hauswand macht,
also direkt eine Hauswand mit Fliesen. Das ist wahnsinnig modern.
Ich weiß, wer die Fliesen ausgesucht hat.
Das Besondere an dem Grundstück ist eigentlich:
Nach dem Zaun geht’s noch weiter.
Ich glaube, du kannst die Bosporusbrücke sehen, wenn diese Bäume
nicht da wären. Genau.
Mein Ziel ist es, alle Bäume komplett abzuholzen, ein riesengroßen
Hotel zu bauen für Tourismus pur, d. h., die ganze Natur zu zerstören.
Das ist jetzt mein Ziel. Das mache ich jetzt.
Nein, das mache ich jetzt nicht!
Bu arsa kimin?
EINE DAME IM HINTERGRUND: Burası hepsi sizin.
MURAT: Bizim mi?
Also, ich habe gerade die Dame gefragt. Das alles gehört uns.
Hier der ganze Buckel runter gehört alles uns. Ich weiß es nicht.
Was macht man mit einem Berg, der komplett nach unten geht?
JOSH: Du kannst eine Skisprungschanze daraus machen.
MURAT: Ja, so ist es. Ich könnte einen Wintersportort daraus machen.
[Schneller Vorlauf]
Das war meine kleine Geschichte aus Istanbul.
Aber vielleicht wird sich das hier auch mal entwickeln.
Vielleicht wird es mal Millionen wert sein, vielleicht in 300 Jahren.
Wenn der Meeresspiegel so hoch ist, dass das Wasser hier unten steht.
Dann ist es vielleicht möglich.
JOSH: So eine schöne Strandlage.
MURAT: Ja, perfekt! Strandlage hast du dann irgendwann einmal,
wenn der Klimawandel weitergeht – eine tolle Investition.
[Musik]
Wir sind jetzt hier in Iznik angekommen.
Iznik gehört zur Provinz Bursa. Hier gibt es auch den Iznik See.
Das ist der fünftgrößte See hier in der Türkei.
Hier lassen wir unsere Keramikflaschen herstellen.
Ich zeige euch jetzt hier unsere Werkstatt
und wie unsere Keramikflasche hergestellt wird.
[Musik]
Das wird mein erstes Mal Töpfern.
Ich hoffe, es gelingt mir ansatzweise eine Form.
Das wird eine individuelle Vase.
[Romantische Musik]
Spielen wir jetzt Ghost? [Murat stimmt zu]
Aber nicht, dass es jetzt schmuddelig wird.
MURAT: Wenn es jetzt schmuddelig wird, höre ich sofort auf.
Ich sag’s dir! Ich gehe da weg. Meine Mutter guckt bestimmt zu.
SALLY: Achtung! Achtung!
MURAT: Cool.
SALLY: Ja, doch! So! Und dann nochmal ein bisschen höher ziehen.
[Starke Windgeräusche]
Nicht meine Vase! Beschützt meine Vase.
Die Welt geht unter, aber beschützt meine Vase.
Stellt euch hin wie eine Mauer! Danke schön! [Lacht]
SARAH: Mich hat ein Ast getroffen.
SALLY: [Lacht] Egal, Sarah! Beschütz die Vase weiter!
Schnell weg, schnell weg!
„Hier nutzt man einfach die natürlichen Eigenschaften von Gips.
Gips...“ Hat er sich den Kopf angestoßen? [Lacht]
[Musik]
MURAT: Bin ich schon fertig?
SALLY: Nein, du bist noch nicht fertig. Bleibe noch ein bisschen!
Ich fühle mich gerade wie die Super-Nanny
und der Murat sitzt auf der stillen Treppe als Disziplinarmaßnahme.
MURAT: [Mit dumpfer Stimme] Ich habe Kopfschmerzen.
SALLY: Er hat es sich ausgesucht. Du bist fertig.
[Musik]
Ich sitze hier auf einem Haufen Hasen-Kaka.
Aber ich habe es mir nicht anmerken lassen.
Alles fürs Bild, Josh! Alles!
JOSH: Okay. Danke! Aber du hast da echt schönes Licht.
SALLY: Ja? [Josh stimmt zu]
Gut, man sitzt auch nicht ganz bequem,
weil das so ein bisschen steinig ist, aber ist okay! Alles fürs Bild!
JOSH: Danke!
SALLY: Danke auch!
Ich will nur betonen, dass das Volkans Idee war.
MURAT: Ja. Der Volkan wollte das so authentisch wie möglich machen
und hat uns eine Folkloregruppe besorgt.
SALLY: Auf die Olivenölplantage.
MURAT: Ja. Volkan, ich bin gebürtiger Balinger.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich da drin aussehen soll...
SALLY: Aber im Herzen Sinoplu.
MURAT: Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, wie man Folklore tanz.
Aber du hattest doch mal...
SALLY: Ich weiß es, denn ich hatte früher...
Also ich war früher selbst, als ich noch ein Kind und Jugendlich war,
war ich selbst in der Folkloregruppe und habe getanzt.
Als ich etwa 16 war, habe ich selbst einen Folkloreunterricht gegeben
und habe praktisch Kaşık Oyunu, also das, was wir in Konya tanzen,
dann Zeybek Harmandalı, was wir jetzt gleich machen
und hatte sogar noch Artvin Oyunu,
also das, was man an der Schwarzmeerküste tanzt.
Also ich hatte meine Folkloregruppe und habe das schon gern gemacht.
Ich habe das aber schon lange nicht mehr getanzt.
Deswegen komm, wir schmeißen uns in die Kleidung.
MURAT: Ich war früher im Palazzo einfach nur...
SALLY: Komm, wir gehen uns umziehen. Bis gleich!
MURAT: Ich sag’s dir! Wenn das meine Mutter sieht
– ich mach dich fertig.
SALLY: Sie ist voll stolz auf dich!
MURAT: Ja. Tschüss. Bis gleich.
SALLY: Warum sagst du eigentlich immer „Tschüss“ mitten im Video?
[Musik]
Okay, seid ihr bereit? Ich drehe mich um. [Lacht]
SARAH: Ich dachte, ich kriege eine Hose.
Jetzt habe ich eine Kopfbedeckung. Volkan!
SALLY: Danke!
SARAH: Danke! Teşekkürler.
SALLY: Sarah weiß es noch nicht,
aber sie wird heute zur türkischen Braut. [Lacht]
SARAH: Heiraten wir?
SALLY: Ich bin schon verheiratet.
MURAT: Die haben, glaube ich, nicht mit meiner Größe gerechnet.
Deswegen haben sie so kleine Schuhe gebracht. Kann das sein?
SALLY: Also Josh hat kein Outfit, weil er zu groß ist.
[Musik]
Na los, es warten schon alle.
Es sind 40°C und wir haben die Outfits an.
MURAT: ... Es würde so viele Oliven geben...
SALLY: Schatz, bitte rede nicht mehr so viel. Es sind 40°C und wir
haben das hier an.
MURAT: Okay, alles klar!
SALLY: Ich schwitze jetzt schon.
MURAT: Los, wir fangen an zu tanzen.
SARAH: Es sind 23°C.
[Musik]
SALLY: Wir sind jetzt hier auch in Aydın. Neben uns sitzt Mahmut.
Vor 2 Jahren haben wir den Mahmut bei uns zu Hause kennengelernt.
Er hat sich vorgestellt – da haben wir gleich gemerkt:
Okay, das passt einfach vom Charakter und Typ her.
[Musik]
MAHMUT: Wahnsinn!
MURAT: [Lacht] Hey, Wahnsinn. Genau.
Jawoll! Wir bringen ihm noch Deutsch bei.
MAHMUT: Ich schwör‘, Wahnsinn!
[Alle lachen]
[Musik]
Auf jeden Fall sind hier die Weinberge,
wenn man von Bergen reden kann.
Ein Berg ist es eigentlich sind; es sind Weinreben.
Es ist richtig cool hier.
Ah, da ist der Mahmut.
Mahmut ist unser begleitendes Volk. Er ist dabei.
Ich mache gerade ein Vlog, Mahmut. Auf Englisch:
I make a vlog.
MAHMUT: You make a blog?
MURAT: Vlog, nicht Blog. Vlog!
Wir sind in Bungalows mit Selbstverpflegung untergebracht.
Ich glaube, der einzige Luxus in diesem Boutique-Hotel
ist dieser Pool und das hier.
Ansonsten ist es eigentlich sehr, sehr cool, muss ich sagen.
Die Gegend gefällt mir. Voll mit Olivenbäumen.
Es sieht so aus, als wären wir in der Toskana.
Ich war noch nie in der Toskana,
aber wenn ich an die Toskana denke, müsste sie so aussehen.
MAHMUT: Das ist schön. [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: It don’t look like Turkey, Mahmut. It... more...
MAHMUT: ... look like Italy?
MURAT: Yes, YES! Your English was good. Super!
Auf jeden Fall sieht es so aus. Seht ihr, hier wird Wein angebaut.
Das ist ein riesengroßen Weinbauangebiet, äh, Weinanbaugebiet.
Da sind Olivenbäume. Wie nennt sich das nochmal? Zesten?
Nein, nicht Zesten - Zypressen. Genau, Zypressen!
Guckt mal, das hier sind die verschiedenen Häuser.
Jetzt gehen wir rein in unser Zimmer, in unser Bungalow.
Und zwar wohnen wir mit dem Josh und der Sarah zusammen.
Also nicht in einem Zimmer, sondern die wohnen im anderen Zimmer.
Aber ich nehme euch einfach mal mit. Mein Gott, ich bin so aufgeregt.
So, Sarah hat hier... Was ist? Hat jemand Durchfall? [Sarah lacht]
Was ist? Hat jemand Durchfall gekriegt? Du musst gleich wieder zeigen,
die Deutschen horten wieder Klopapier, kann das sein?
Das ist typisch Deutsch. Genau das habe ich in meinem Vlog gebraucht.
Mein Gott! Gott sei Dank, haben wir noch Klopapier.
So, dann geht’s rein.
SARAH: Leute!
MURAT: Hast du gesehen, sagt Sally.
Der Deutsche ist wieder gleich rüber und hat Klopapier geklaut.
SALLY: Ja, natürlich!
MURAT: Hier ist unsere WG. Sally hier am Spülen.
SALLY: Wir haben keine Spülmaschine.
MURAT: Das ist Sarah und das ist der Josh.
Der Josh schneidet gerade die Videos.
Mir macht der Vlog irgendwie voll Spaß gerade.
Auf jeden Fall ist Josh am Arbeiten.
SALLY: Darf ich eines sagen?
MURAT: Warte kurz...
SALLY: Dass wir hier keine Weinparty hatten, aber dass das
ein Weingut ist und man hat nur Weingläser und keine Wassergläser.
SARAH: Wir trinken unser Kurkuma.
SALLY: Ja, guck! Immer Kurkuma, jeden Abend.
Das ist Kurkuma, Gerstengras, Brennesel und Hagebutte.
MURAT: Hast du das aus Deutschland mitgebracht? [Sally bejaht]
Weil es in der Türkei nichts Besonderes gibt, gell?
Mein Gott, echt!
SALLY: Jeden Abend...
SARAH: Hey, das ist gut für... also entzündungshemmend, gut für
Vitamin C, für die Nägel, für die Haare, für die Haut, ...
SALLY: Für den Stuhlgang.
SARAH: Genau, für den Stuhlgang.
MURAT: Ja, ich habe es gerade gemerkt, weil Klopapier...
Das ist das Erste, was die Deutschen horten, wenn sie im Urlaub sind:
Klopapier, kann das sein, Sarah? [Sarah stimmt zu]
SARAH: Es könnte was passieren.
MURAT: So, auf jeden Fall ist das unser Wohnzimmer.
Hier ist Mahmut.
MAHMUT: Hallo.
SALLY: Misafirimiz bugün. Kusura bakma pasta yapmadım.
MURAT: Die Betten habe ich heute selbst gemacht.
So sehen sie auch aus. So ist es doch richtig schön, Leute. Ich weiß,
es ist jetzt nicht Upper Class, aber das wollten wir auch gar nicht.
Wenn wir in die Türkei in den Urlaub gehen,
dann suchen wir uns immer nach Möglichkeit Hotels,
wo wir uns selbst verpflegen können und wo wir außerhalb essen können.
Also wir sind keine All Inclusive-Hotelgänger.
Das reicht eigentlich schon. Guck mal, dieser Ausblick – wunderschön!
So, das ist meine Frau.
SALLY: Hättest du nicht vorher aufräumen können?
MURAT: Das ist mein Kleiderschrank. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Komm, ich zeige noch das Bad.
MURAT: Bad? Das ist eine Oase! Das ist ein Wellness-Tempel.
Zeigst du mal unseren Wellness-Tempel?
SALLY: Also hier ist mein Platz zum...
Also hier habe ich meine Körpercreme, schminken, föhnen,
denn das Badezimmer ist zu klein. [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: So, jetzt gehen wir ins Badezimmer. Warte, warte kurz.
Ich hole kurz...
SALLY: Aber was ich hier schön finde, ist,
dass man hier so einen Schrank hat. Ich habe ihn jetzt nicht benutzt,
weil mein Koffer einfach gut aufgeräumt ist, gell?
MURAT: Ja, meiner auch.
Und hier sind wir im Bad. Das ist kein Bad – das ist eine Dusche...
SALLY: Ich habe mir jedes Mal beim Rein- und Rausgehen
den Kopf angeschlagen.
MURAT: Komisch, dass sich jeder den Kopf einschlägt
und ich mache das nicht.
SALLY: Sarah, Josh und ich schlagen uns...
JOSH AUS DEM HINTERGRUND: Das liegt an der Körpergröße, kann das sein?
MURAT: Nein, das liegt nicht an der Körpergröße. Das ist einfach...
Ihr lauft mit Absätzen rein, deswegen!
Okay, und hier machen wir Kaffee.
Wenn die Kaffeemaschinenmarke schon “Hilfe” heißt [Alle lachen],
dann müsst ihr aufpassen. Ansonsten saumäßig geil.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen...
Würdest du das Hotel empfehlen? Ich definitiv! Ich würde es empfehlen.
SALLY: Kommt drauf an, was man will.
MURAT: Ja okay. Also wenn ihr Touri-Urlaub machen wollt
mit Vollbedienung und allem Drum und Dran, dann bleibt daheim.
Aber wenn ihr was Cooles erleben wollt in einer coolen Gegend,
wunderschön und natürlich, finde ich, ist es der Wahnsinn.
Ganz ehrlich!
SALLY: Ein bisschen mehr Wasserstrahl würde ich mir wünschen.
MURAT: Ja, mein Gott! Das ist ja nicht schlimm.
Josh, sei mal ehrlich – du bist so ein Typ...
SARAH: WLAN! Ich würde mir WLAN wünschen. [Josh stimmt zu]
SALLY: Ja gut, das ist für uns echt blöd, weil wir arbeiten
und wir müssen ja auch Daten und Video alle hochladen.
Da haben wir echt ein Problem: Wir haben kein WLAN.
SARAH: Jetzt leben wir alle von Sallys Hotspot.
MURAT: Aber jetzt mal ehrlich, Josh.
Du warst schon jahrelang in Australien. Habe ich recht?
JOSH: Ja, fast ein Jahr.
MURAT: Wenn du das jetzt vergleichst – ich finde es wunderschön!
Würdest du nochmal herkommen?
JOSH: Ja, auf jeden Fall. [Murat stimmt zu]
Ist so ein bisschen rustikal, aber voll schön.
Also ich mag das auf diesem Weingut.
SALLY: Ich finde es auch cool.
Wie gesagt, ich hätte mir nur ein bisschen mehr Hygiene gewünscht.
MURAT: Ja, aber da werden wir schon nicht dran sterben.
JOSH: Hygiene hin, Hygiene her...
MURAT: Ja genau, Pandemie hin, Pandemie her...
SALLY: Tatsächlich finde ich am coolsten: Wir haben echt unsere Ruhe.
Wir haben ja auch alle drei unsere Zimmer in einem Gebäude.
SARAH: Wir haben eine WG.
SALLY: Wie so eine WG, Tatsache. Es ist auch einfach so,
wenn Murat und ich sprechen, dann kann uns Sarah antworten.
MURAT: Also, wir gehen alle raus.
SALLY: Ihr könnt schon einmal raus.
MURAT: Hast du meine Sachen eingepackt, und meine Badehose,
eine Jacke, Tasche reingetan. Hast du mein Zeug schon gerichtet?
SALLY: Nein, ich richte nicht dein Zeug. Ich bin nicht deine Mutter!
MURAT: So, ich mache kurz die Kamera aus. Wir machen es kurz wie bei
Batman „Piff, Puff, Peng“ und dann ist alles fertig.
[Alle lachen]
SARAH: Bei uns macht es auch „Piff, Puff, Peng“
MURAT: Was hast du mit dem Klopapier vor?
SALLY: „Piff, Puff, Peng“ [Lacht]
MURAT: Wollt ihr mich verar***en?
Ihr nehmt beide Klopapier mit auf die Reise?
SARAH: Wir können uns ja wieder unterhalten,
wenn wir auf dem Klo sind.
SALLY: Geht ihr schon einmal raus bitte. Uns ist das unangenehm.
MURAT: Ja ne, das hat noch gefehlt. Josh, komm, gehen wir raus!
JOSH: Ja warte, komm!
SALLY: Kriege ich mein Handy bitte?
MURAT: Ja. Da, nimm dein Handy.
Nein, hör auf, mich zu zeigen! Hör auf, mich zu zeigen!
Josh, komm.
JOSH: Ja warte, warte!
SALLY: Richtet ihr das Auto? [Murat bejaht]
Nimmst du den Koffer?
MURAT: Wir hängen schon mal den Duftbaum ins Auto.
JOSH: Ja, machen die Fenster auf, damit es durchzieht.
SALLY: Äh, nehmt ihr Mahmut vielleicht auch mit? [Alle lachen]
MURAT: Mahmut, we go to...
SALLY: Sende gel. (Komm auch mit)
MURAT: Come with me. Come with me. Good morning.
MAHMUT: Tschüss!
SALLY: He speaks free from the liver. [Alle lachen]
JOSH: Tschüss!
SALLY: Okay Sarah, bis gleich.
SARAH: Bis gleich.
MURAT: Ich mach‘ doch schon. Warum guckst du mich so an?
SALLY: [Lacht] Wir müssen schneller arbeiten. [Summt]
Ich habe vergessen zu stoppen, weil ich zu dir geguckt habe
[Sarah lacht]
Oh mein Gott!
MAHMUT: Ah Sally, ne yaptın? Bu çok ciddi bir iş.
SALLY: Biliyorum.
MURAT: Ich würde dich feuern! Ich schwöre, ich würde dich feuern!
SALLY: Murat’a baktım, Sarah’ya kameraya güldüm.
Çeşmeyi kapatmaya unuttum.
MAHMUT: We need full concentration.
SALLY: Ah, ich heule gleich! Ich heule echt gleich. Ich war abgelenkt.
[TikTok „Weee“]
[Fotoapparat]
[Musik]
Wir sind jetzt hier in Efes. Efes ist auch ein ganz historischer Ort.
Efes war in der antiken Stadt eher am Meer, also an der Küste.
Jetzt ist aber durch die klimatischen Veränderungen die Stadt
wirklich so ein bisschen ins Landesinnere gewandert.
[Musik]
SARAH: Zeig mir den Wind in deinem Haar. Show me. Show me.
Zu mir zwinkern. Zwinkern! Blinzeln! Blinzeln! Oh ja!
Von rechts! Von links! Wedeln!
[Alle lachen]
Ich wollte nur machen, was die Frauen da oben machen.
SARAH: Das können wir auch.
[Musik von King Sis: „Yeah you“]
SONG: „Yeah you/You always made me feel like home/Yeah you”
JOSH: Ähm [Räuspert],
kommst du dir so ein ganz kleines bisschen blöd vor eigentlich?
SALLY: Die kennen mich ja nicht.
SONG: „You never leave my thoughts alone/Yeah you/
You‘re the reason I’m going out my mind”
Ich meine, wir hatten jetzt viel Stein, aber wirkt das nicht ein
bisschen kühl und wir brauchen Pflanzen für die Emotionalität?
Ah, Bäume! Wir könnten durch die Bäume durch. [Josh stimmt zu]
Dann wird’s auch nochmal natürlicher. [Josh stimmt zu]
SONG: „I just can't stop thinkin’ about you”
JOSH: Okay, danke! Passt. Riecht der Baum überhaupt nach irgendetwas?
SALLY: Nein, der riecht echt neutral.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das für ein Baum ist. Oh, da ist eine Katze!
JOSH: Okay.
[Song]
Ich bin immer so traurig, wenn ich aus der Türkei zurückfliege.
[Musik]
Zwar schon so zurück nach Hause, aber irgendwie hat man doch
so eine Heimatverbundenheit, und es war so schön!
[Emotionale Musik]
Jetzt sind wir wieder angekommen.
JOSH: Wer fährt nach Hause?
SALLY: Was? Wer fährt nach Hause?
MURAT: So, los! Mach!
JOSH: Okay, einmal.
BEIDE: Schnick, Schnack, Schnuck.
JOSH: [Schneidegeräusche]
SALLY: Hast du gerade geschimpft? [Murat verneint]
JOSH: Sünnet! [Alle lachen]
SALLY: Jetzt geht’s nach Hause.
Es war schön und wir sind auch sehr traurig.
Wir haben auch beide... okay, ich... ich habe geweint.
SARAH: Ich bin auch traurig.
[Emotionale Musik]
JOSH: Honey comes for breakfast – a poet!
[Gespräche im Hintergrund von anderen Gästen]
[Emotionale Musik]
SALLY: Ich zeige hier Josh am Bosporus für die schönsten Aufnahmen.
[Stimmungsvolle Musik]
[Emotionale Musik]
[Klangvolle Musik]
[Josh lacht]
SALLY: Soll ich Licht machen? Ist alles zu dunkel? [Josh bejaht]
Voll der Fail.
Soll ich Licht machen? [Josh bejaht]
Es geht immer aus! [Josh lacht]
SALLY: Ja. Warte, warte, warte!
Wir müssen erst wieder in die richtige Position.
Warte, ich bin jetzt gerade rein.
Wenn Sarah gerade drin ist, gehst du außen. Also...
MURAT, SALLY UND SARAH: Jetzt!
SALLY: Merhaba.
„Peace up, A-Town down/Yeah!/Okay!/Usher!”
[Musik von Usher: „Yeah!“]